over the last episodes we've seen how to
go from notebook code to a deployed
model in the cloud
but in reality an ml workflow is rarely
that linear a huge part of the machine
learning process is experimentation and
tuning you'll probably need to try out
different hyper parameters different
architectures or even different hardware
configurations before you figure out
what works best for your use case
so today we'll cover a few vertex ai
features that can help you with tuning
and scaling your ml models
specifically we'll look at hyper
parameter tuning distributed training
and experiment tracking i'm nikita and
this is prototype to production
let's get to it
[Music]
let's start with hyper parameter tuning
which is the process of discovering the
optimal hyper parameters for your model
and use case if you're only trying to
tune a handful of hyper parameters you
might be able to run experiments
manually
but when you start juggling hyper
parameters for your model's architecture
the optimizer finding the best batch
size and learning rate
automating these experiments at scale
quickly becomes a necessity and it's not
just about tracking the results from all
of these trials you also want a way to
efficiently search the space of possible
values so you don't waste as much time
trying out combinations that yield low
accuracy scores
vertex ai training which we used in a
previous episode includes a
hyperparameter tuning service
a vertex ai hyper parameter tuning job
will run multiple trials of your
training code
on each trial it will use different
values for your chosen hyper parameters
set within limits that you specify
to run a hyperparameter tuning job
you'll need to make two changes to your
code first you'll need to define a
command line argument in your main
training module for each hyper parameter
you want to tune
you'll need to use the value passed in
those arguments to set the corresponding
hyperparameter and your application's
code
so for example your optimizer might look
something like this
you'll also need to report the metric
you want to optimize such as accuracy to
vertex ai using the cloud ml hypertune
python package
the metric is important because we don't
just want to run multiple trials of our
code we also want a way to track which
one performed the best
when you configure the tuning job either
through the ui or the sdk you'll specify
the type the scale and values for each
hyper parameter as well as the metric
you want to optimize
by default vertex ai training will use
bayesian optimization to search the
space of possible hyperparameter values
this means that information from prior
experiments is used to select the next
set of values making the search more
efficient
when the tuning job is done you'll see
the results of each trial in the ui and
you can select the values that maximize
your given metric
full details on how to try this out with
our flower example are in the code lab
linked below
training a model once takes long enough
so having to run multiple trials of your
training code each with different values
can be very time consuming
and the longer each training trial takes
the slower your progress will be so next
we'll look at distributed training which
is an approach to help you train faster
and faster training makes for faster
iteration to reach your modeling goals
distributed training is when you train a
machine learning model using multiple
accelerators like gpus or tpus on a
single machine
or when you train across multiple
machines that each might have multiple
accelerators you'll need to make sure
that the framework you're using to build
your model supports distributed training
for example both tensorflow and pytorch
include distributed training modules
once you've updated your training code
the main concept you'll need to
understand from the vertex ai side is
worker pools
vertex ai provides four worker pools to
cover the different types of machine
tasks for distributed training jobs
you can think of a worker as a single
machine
and each worker pool as a collection of
machines performing similar tasks
worker pool zero configures the primary
worker also known as the chief or
scheduler
there's only ever one primary worker so
your worker count for worker pool zero
will always be one the most basic setup
for training on vertex ai would be
configuring this worker pool with one
machine
that's exactly what we did when we
trained our model in an earlier video
to speed up training we could add one
gpu
and to speed up training even more we
could use distributed training by adding
multiple gpus
again note that distributed training
does require making changes to your code
first for example tensorflow can make
use of one gpu automatically with no
code changes required however if you
want to train with two or more gpus then
you'll have to do a bit of extra work
because tensorflow needs to know how to
coordinate the training process across
the multiple gpus in your runtime
now if you wanted to take your
distributed training to the next level
and use more than one machine that's
when you'll need to configure additional
worker pools
worker pool 1 is where you can add
additional workers to your cluster
worker pool 2 is where you can add
parameter servers or reduction server
reducers
worker pull 3 is where you can add any
optional evaluators
how you configure these different pools
and the combination of workers reducers
evaluators etc will depend entirely on
the ml framework and distribution
strategy that you're using in your
training code a sample is linked below
if you want to try out distributed
training for the flower example on a
single machine or on multiple machines
finally to track and manage all of your
experiments you can use the vertex ai
experiment tracking service and vertex
ai managed tensorboard
tensorboard is an open source project
for machine learning experiment
visualization
it includes features like visualizing
metrics over time viewing histograms of
weights and biases or other tensors
projecting embeddings to a lower
dimensional space and much more
in addition to the open source features
vertex ai tensorboard provides a
persistent shareable link to your
experiments dashboard a searchable list
of all experiments in a project and
enterprise grade security privacy and
compliance the simplest way to use
vertex ai tensorboard in tensorflow code
is by adding the keras tensorboard
callback to your training loop
you'll write your tensorboard logs to a
cloud storage bucket that vertex ai
training will automatically make
available via a predefined environment
variable called aip tensorboard dur as
shown here
for even more flexibility vertex ai has
an experiment tracking service
you can track parameters and metrics of
models trained locally in your notebook
and see the results in the experiment
dashboard
you can create and view an experiment
lineage to understand the factors that
contributed to your experiment
and track and compare pipeline runs
to try this sdk out for yourself check
out the resources below
you now know all the basics of getting
models out of experimentation and into
production with vertex ai
but just like how experimentation is
iterative so is the deployment process
your work doesn't stop when you get a
model hosted on the cloud
vertex ai also includes additional tools
we didn't cover in the series that can
help you to build repeatable reusable
serving pipelines
monitor the quality of models over time
and much more
if there's a topic you'd like to learn
more about let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching and be sure to
check out all of the code labs
it's time for you to run some
experiments of your own
[Music]